if you were looking to be an evil prick
and do damage you could do with this no
one's talking about betting that kind of
firearm why because it's wood we're
going to debunk today let's go through
the top ar-15 myths because that's what
everyone is talking about so first
question the day what do you think is
this really about banning ar-15s after
the shooting do you think that'll work
or is it a Trojan horse I genuinely want
to know because right now and it seems
whenever there's a public shooting they
pick a topic and right now it is ar-15
that's enemy numero uno as opposed to
going after all guns which i think is a
little bit of a bait-and-switch
so let's this is making the rounds
everywhere things like this regarding
the ar-15 here's a woman only way that I
can know for sure that this gun will
never hurt anyone is if it doesn't exist
I'm not gonna let the Second Amendment
anymore use as an excuse for considering
children as collateral damage in this
country the only way to ensure that her
name an object did not harm somebody it
makes sense that we found the rifle in
question yeah oh yeah it's [ __ ] and then
this is been making the rounds this guy
destroying is ar-15 it's everywhere it's
all over Facebook can occupy Facebook
Democrats for Bernie Sanders whatever
watch when do we make laws that say
maybe a weapon like this isn't
acceptable in today's society is the
right to own this weapon more important
in someone's life
there's so many of them out there now
one less no there is one more highly
illegal rifle highly highly illegal
rifle that no longer fits the
government's requirements I hope someone
sends somebody after me now I know
obviously the spirit of it as sawed-off
shotgun because of the spread but still
you're not allowed to do that sawed-off
shotguns by the way also most places
very good idea that what's the point
that's why they're illegal boat I the
fact that that I don't think that was
his gun so little about firearms and
firearm safety I do not I believe he
borrowed in Eric I believe he borrowed a
fake ar-15 and the Illuminati that was
the kel-tec air 15 so let's go through
the top claims that usually hear about
ar-15s myths myth number one ar-fifteens
are the most deadly firearms in the
world sir certainly the most deadly
available to the public we've been
hearing this a lot lately this sort of
claim made by someone like Senator
Nelson there you go you're looking at
somebody who supports the Second
Amendment
they always prep right to bear arms I
grew in Florida on a ranch I have always
had done since I was a little boy I have
hunted too all my life I still hunt with
my son but an ar-15 is not for hunting
it's for killing well how do you hunt
that kills - I don't like to kill my
prey I'd like to just woo noon when I go
a lot of dirt a grizzly I just want to
get really pissed off and of course this
echoes a statement that the notorious
statement now those made by a Joe Biden
not that long ago
you don't need an ar-15 it's harder to
aim it's harder to use and in fact you
don't need 30 rounds to protect yourself
is that a fact gun fire shotgun fire
indiscriminately into the air so there
they have a game most like 30 people yes
first off guns are killing tools ok and
this is why things fall Lordan they're
killing tools so if you're just gonna
ban one because you're saying it's more
effective at killing it's not about the
air 15 it's that you you want to ban
firearms and I really do believe that's
the overall agenda here and I'll get to
watch because even with just rifles
we're talking about a ar-15s but just
rifles there are plenty of firearms out
there that are more dangerous than
ar-15s if you're just talking about
one life there are plenty more rifles
that are semi-automatic that can carry
as much ammo as they are 15s that use
ammunition that's as powerful or more
powerful than the ar-15 the two two
three it's not anything formidable some
argue it's basically a varmint round
it's really it's lighter for the
military to carry some examples of these
firearms no one's talking for example
about the Ruger mini 30 it looks
unassuming enough except that's the same
firearm on the bottom that's the exact
same gun by the way it fires the same
caliber as an ak-47 something have you
heard anyone talk about banning what is
commonly used for deer hunting or
certainly bird hunting semi-automatic
shotguns have you heard any talk about
that no this is what they can do now
let's look at the side-by-side damage in
a ballistics gelatin test from a
12-gauge versus a 2 to 3 now some people
can get mad at me saying don't do this
littles gonna want to take away the
12-gauge is now don't blame me ok they
are these facts aren't what they are
don't blame me semi-automatic not even
rifles now hey nuts Glock 17 it's used
by law enforcement Glock 17 19 I think
it's the most popular firearm platform
the world in the world period 17 rounds
in that magazine Wow do your people
talking about banning those but my
favorite one of my favorite farms this
is a basic lever action so this is
actually one of the few that's not
semi-automatic because of the lever
action this holds 13 rounds of 357
Magnum arguably the most effective
handgun round on demand don't get into a
caliber where right now it's that much
more effective when coming out of a
longer rifled barrel just how fast could
you shoot this firearm here's a world
record granted he's the exception not
the rule but realistically 13 rounds to
three percent of Magnum myself.you shot
with this yeah what kind of ten let's
say watermelon unloaded just to make
sure you know yeah watermelon size
target of 50 yards how fast could you
shoot this probably about if you were
looking to be an evil prick and do
damage you could do with this no one's
talking about banning that kind of
firearm why because it's wood the maple
never heard him it looks less of salt it
looks less of salty it doesn't have the
googly eyes on it so myth number two and
this is one that's it's really fast
let's just come over this is that a R
stands for assault rifle it stands for
Armalite I'm late that's the company in
cave mama
fortunately name for them but you know
just we're not gonna providing google it
so myth number three that the ar-15 is
an automatic rifle you hear this a lot
so it's you don't need it it's the most
dangerous firearm out there it's an
automatic rifle claimed by the media
here's Don Lemon saying just that I
think most people can go out and buy an
automatic weapon automatic weapon what
is your definition automatically well
for me an automatic weapon is something
that you can shoot off a number of
rounds a number of rounds very quickly I
was able to buy a ar-15 for me
personally my truth my pal assault
weapons yeah personally for Donnie it's
like you can buy a scud missile at your
local 7-eleven but but but Don Lemon
that's just a hot tamale for me it's a
Scud missiles 20 minutes later after I
eat it it's a Scud that's how they hedge
it Bernie by Bernie Sanders categorized
he characterized the Orlando the
six-hour of it
in the same way here you but I got to
tell you you know over 25 years ago I
believe that in this Georgian engines
are always selling automatic weapons
which are designed to kill people
didn't chew on frogs you would prefer a
weapon that isn't designed to kill
people here's like what you want a gun
that doesn't kill you want a gun that
isn't effective for hunting that's what
either you want guns or you don't either
you believe someone has the right to
protect themselves or you don't you
can't say I believe you the right to
protect yourself but not if it's a
firearm that can kill people maim is
okay because in a life-and-death
situation you want something that isn't
going to I just it's there there are two
factions when it comes to the gun
control argument and it's horrible
tragedy
get it on no one here wants more mass
shootings okay so we're all just you see
it's time to have a conversation we've
been having this conversation every
single day on the show and so we've been
having it in the gun community for a
long time you're late to the party all
right that's what's happening right here
yours it's not a new conversation you
just don't know what you're talking
about there are two factions people who
own firearms or who have ever fired
firearms and the uninformed and that's
the gun control crop that's it there's
no one between now the truth is at the
air 15 it's not an automatic it's a
semi-automatic now most people they
don't really leave that semi is just a
raising heroic right and they just perk
Sammy automatic just means you pull the
trigger once and one bullet comes out so
for the record all pistols pretty much
effectively are semi automatics okay
and the shotguns that I just showed you
a lot of rifles I just show you a lot of
22s revolvers are not technically
semi-automatic but they act a
semi-automatic right there double-action
revolvers you pull the trigger once and
one bullet come lining around but it's
the same for all intents and purposes
it's the same ultimate effect so when
you use a term we need to ban these semi
automatics well when you're talking
about everything you know just talk
about ar-15 so you're talking about
everything alright myth number four
ar-15 or similar rifles are responsible
for most gun violence this is something
you hear a lot the truth according the
FBI itself you're four times as likely
to die from being knifed to death then
you are from being shot by a rifle and
2016 handguns at all rifle soon that's
all right folks and in 2016 handguns
killed roughly 19 times as many people
as all rifles put together again I know
people saying we just need a ban
handguns exactly that's my point
you're either talk you're not talking
about banning the air 15 because if
we're talking about it's time to get
practical about gun control and time to
come up with solutions real talk here's
the final myth that we taught this is
the big one this is the crux of an ar-15
this idea that there's a weapon of
choice for mass shooters because that's
what they're telling you right now
listen we support the Second Amendment
but this is the choice of metal why
should people be able to get we could
eliminate mass shootings if we just got
rid of the weapon of choice for mass
shooters here's a claim from CNN's
pullian Chief Chris Cuomo the shootings
that we've seen with this it just keeps
being used for these massacres because
of all of these features I just told you
about it being easy to use and all this
fire and the caliber bullet and all the
damage it can do literally everything
wrong about every myth that we just went
through to summarize the whole thing all
the fire and all the caliber you pull
the trigger a bullet comes out we can't
have that it's a semi-automatic that's
the rate of fire and the caliber isn't
any more powerful and most hunting
rounds you dumbass the New York Times by
the way I did a review on weapons used
in recent mass shootings more reason
mass shootings 11 out of 19 didn't use
rifles of any sort
okay Virginia Tech those handguns aren't
only ar-15 they're Virginia Tech so
this isn't really indication that
limiting ar-15 style guns would
specifically have an impact on such but
any of these killings this is the thing
that you have to go with the premise
okay
we're pro Second Amendment but can we
find common ground is banning ar-15
why well because they they're the most
dangerous that's not true they have a
caliber that's what that's not true and
they're using most mass shootings that's
not true none of those things are true
so why are we talking about banning the
air 15 what was the assault weapons ban
Act was that just about the ar-15 what
did it extend to this is the thing that
people need to need understand you can
watch everything that's been presented
here okay and you can this is what I
think and that's why I want you to
comment below people right now I know
are just panicking going don't show
people how easy it is to use the
lever-action rail because then liberals
are gonna want to ban that or go don't
show them how how popular the clock 17
is with 17 runs cuz they're going to
wanna ban that and then people on either
side are going I had no idea I just want
to ban that gun and that got in that gun
everything you just talked about let's
ban revolvers here's the truth you can
look at all of the information presented
the factual information that we
presented here today and respond one of
two ways okay maybe I was wrong about
the ar-15 and potentially firearms in
general or you can watch this video and
say we just have to ban all the thing
there is no in between you have to pick
one
one is constitutionally justifiable one
isn't you just have to find out where
you line up and be honest about it just
don't go out telling everyone that it's
just about the scary black rifle or the
ar-15 because it's not hey did you like
this video it what you didn't oh you're
a cat person well that makes sense
disregard him and or her /z everyone
else hit the subscribe button and leave
your comment below as to why you like
this video i you know what crazy cat you
can get back you can you can comment
below to as to why you don't like it